bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
Victor Castanet bonsoir prix Albert
Londres 2022 pour votre enquête choc une
véritable déflagration les fossoyeurs
chez Faya et vous revenez avec 10
nouveaux chapitres toujours chez Fayard
où vous montrer les pressions les
intimidations même dont vous avez fait
l'objet avant la parution de votre livre
certaines mêmes sont passées par
l'Assemblée nationale on va y revenir on
a du temps on est ensemble pendant une
heure pour décrypter l'actualité de ce
jeudi 2 février au sommaire ce soir
travaillez-moi pour vivre plus c'est
peut-être l'angle mort de la réforme des
retraites la valeur travail pour les
Français a beaucoup changé moins
importante la place du travail moins
centrale dans nos vies cette valeur a
perdu un peu de sens au point que
certains ministres dégaines in extremis
la question de la semaine des quatre
jours alors trop tard ou pas ce sera
notre grand débat ce soir dans avec nos
invités avant de retrouver à 20h15 nos
parties pris nos affranchis et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr avec Elsa
montanava l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée Victor Castanet vous me
suivez
[Musique]
peut-on demander aux gens de travailler
plus si on leur promet pas de travail
est mieux le bras de fer sur la réforme
des retraites nous renvoie donc à la
place que nous accordons au travail
aujourd'hui dans nos vies notre rapport
à la valole travail la charge que nous
portons avec ce mot cette valeur est le
moins qu'on puisse dire et bien c'est
que les choses ont beaucoup changé bon
soir mode région bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes député renaissance
des Hauts-de-Seine porte-parole du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée en face
de vous Farida Amrani bienvenue sur ce
plateau député la France insoumise de
l'Essonne bonsoir Dominique Médard
bonsoir vous êtes sociologue du travail
vous dirigez le laboratoire de sciences
sociales de l'Université Paris Dauphine
et puis vous alerter depuis assez
longtemps maintenant sur la dégradation
des conditions de travail vous avez même
fait une tribune on en parlera dans le
monde il y a à peine quelques jours
bonsoir Jérémy PLT bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ravi de vous retrouver vous
diriger la Fondation Jean Jaurès la
fondation qui a publié il y a quelques
semaines à un rapport passionnant
intitulé je t'aime moi non plus sur les
ambivalences du nouveau rapport au
travail on va et revenir Victor Castanet
votre enquête elle parle aussi de la
souffrance au travail des acteurs des
EHPAD la perte de sens donc évidemment
votre regard dans ce débat nous
intéresse vous pouvez intervenir quand
quand vous le souhaitez on va commencer
par planter le décor avec le billet de
Blacko comme chaque soir il a 200
secondes pour nous expliquer ce qu'il y
a 100 g le chrono de la côte tout de
suite
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir du haut de votre extrade
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous puisque
vous êtes deux on peut dire tous alors
je sais pas si vous savez Myriam mais
d'ailleurs je m'adresse à vous tous la
paresse est l'un des 7 péchés capitaux
c'est-à-dire que vu que plus grand monde
ne va à la messe je sais pas si vous
êtes au courant mais c'est un péché
mortel c'est un péché qui vous emmène
direct en enfer donc si vous voulez une
image voilà en gros pendant des siècles
on a représenté l'appareil de cette
manière là on a deux fois la même image
voyez on est avachi et on fume et on
fait pas son ménage on connaît le
proverbe la paresse et la mère de toutes
les vis mais il y a aussi une version je
suis pas en train de faire le catéchisme
il y a une version Lake qu'on a tous
appris à l'école vous la connaissez par
cœur mais si souvenez-vous ah oui maître
fourmis sur son arbre perché Tenait dans
ses pattes un fromage et mettre cigale
par l'odeur à lécher bon je ne vous
raconte pas la suite bref la paresse a
donc mauvaise réputation et ça aussi
vous le savez les bravo j'en aime pas
que j'en suis une autre route que et
donc Sandrine Rousseau elle elle s'en
fout un petit peu ce que pensent les
braves gens donc elle l'a dit nettement
regardez c'était Roussel contre Rousseau
autant Roussel de communiste n'était pas
tellement pour cette expression de droit
à l'appareil autant
Rousseau elle le défendait l'ADIL 15
septembre elle l'a répété c'était en
commission des affaires sociales
il y a quelques jours on l'écoute
l'éloge de droit à la paresse qu'en 1950
nous travaillons 1900 chers parents
quand aujourd'hui nous ont travaillons
1400 en moyenne et que c'est ça le sens
du progrès donc maintenant il faut
vraiment ouvrir les yeux sur notre
système économique et social oui elle
apparaisse et oui à la réduction du
temps de travail
elle assume complètement alors vous me
connaissez Myriam vous mais les publics
oui j'essaie de rester neutre
habituellement mais là je suis obligé de
reconnaître que Sandrine Rousseau a
raison effectivement le travail c'est
plutôt une valeur de droite regardez ce
que disent les sondages on commence par
le bas la réussite le mérite l'effort ça
c'est des valeurs de droite les valeurs
associées au travail mais c'est ce sont
les Français qui s'expriment et en
revanche quand on leur dit loisir je
t'ai la paresse l'assistana ça ce sont
plutôt des valeurs de gauche donc je
sais pas si les gens de droite et de
gauche se reconnaissent bien dans ces
valeurs sur le plateau ce qui est sûr
c'est que Gérald Darmanin enfin
politique a bien vu le clivage et quand
il y a clivage on fonce et donc
évidemment interview parisien le travail
ce n'est pas une maladie mais on le
connaît Gérald Darmanin que c'est qu'il
a été formé par Nicolas Sarkozy regarder
j'ai retrouvé des belles images de
complicité entre eux donc travailler
plus pour gagner plus voilà c'est
quelque chose qui lui parle alors on
pourrait poser la question aux Français
est-ce que vous pensez que ça vaut le
coup de travailler plus pour gagner plus
on fait des sondages mais les sondages
franchement je veux savoir rien dire les
sondages regardez ça c'est ce que dit
Jean Jaurès qui donc est un institut
plutôt de gauche sinon pourquoi ça plaît
Jean-Jaurès donc ils disent il y a
effectivement 61% des Français qui sont
prêts à travailler moins pour avoir plus
de temps libre mais si c'est monté
moins pour avoir en échange plus de
temps libre mais si on demande à
Montaigne il pose la question un peu
différemment est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
travailler moins mais pour gagner moins
là il y a plus que 15% donc ça dépend
vraiment de la manière dont on formule
la question les gens veulent bien
travailler moins pour avoir plus de
temps libre mais ils veulent pas
travailler moins pour gagner moins donc
travailler plus travailler moins on sent
que le débat là il faut que je conclue
j'ai 200 secondes c'est-à-dire que même
au gouvernement n'est pas d'accord on a
vu Darmanin travailler plus mais
regardez Gabriel Attal lui il veut
plutôt travailler moins seulement quatre
jours il voudrait faire cette et c'est
là et je vous montre que c'est
exactement ce que les écolos proposent
enfin eux ils veulent 32 heures enfin
ils veulent 4 jours donc alors moi je
sais pas comment vous allez faire parce
que travailler plus ok travailler moins
ok je sais pas mais il y a un débat en
tout cas c'est sûr
du coup Stéphane Maud Bregeon c'est vrai
que on se pose tous la question à chaque
fois c'est le rapport de force les
retraites on s'attend à des
manifestations sauf que là dans les
cortèges on comprend bien que c'est le
rapport au travail qui a changé et ça
arrive maintenant cette réforme est-ce
que vous avez pas au fond était un peu
aveugle est-ce que vous avez pas été
dans une forme de déni sur cette
question là est-ce que demander dedans
de plus à un moment où tout change sur
la question du travail c'était le bon
moment je crois que vous l'avez dans
votre introduction l'enjeu c'est c'est
pas travailler moins c'est travailler
mieux effectivement le rapport au
travail a changé et c'est notamment le
cas pour ma génération moi je l'ai vu
quand je suis sortie d'école
d'ingénieurs
on allait plus dans des métiers pour y
passer l'intégralité de nos vies
l'intégralité de nos carrières et
l'intégralité de notre temps pour autant
je crois que le travail demeure
absolument central et que la question du
travail en tant que valeur morale
transcende aujourd'hui un large pan de
la population valeur morale de valeur
morale c'est Olivier qui utilisait cette
expression et utilisait de morale de
l'effort et je crois qu'il a
parfaitement raison et que c'est encore
d'actualité 60% des Français accorde une
place très importante au travail en 1990
ils sont trois fois moins nombreux
aujourd'hui parce que le rapport au
travail a changé et je vais terminer sur
une chose le travail c'est quoi c'est
bien sûr un apport pécunier c'est ce qui
fait que vous payez votre loyer que vous
payez votre facture c'est aussi une
notion d'utilité sociale et ça je crois
que c'est extrêmement important c'est la
coiffeuse qui va montrer sa coupe à sa
cliente c'est l'électricien qui monte au
poteau pour réalimenter un village qui a
été déconnecté d'électricité et que
c'est ce qui fait au fond on se sent pas
inutile au monde et qu'on arrive à avoir
un vecteur extrêmement fort de
sociabilisation et c'est ce qui fait en
tout cas ce qui fonde aujourd'hui
l'importance que nous au sein de la
majorité on a joué ou faire circuler la
parole mais quand je vous écoute vous
êtes dans la majorité j'entends utilité
rapport social au monde on est loin de
la vision de Gérald Darmanin
aussi cette réforme des retraites au
fond elle propose un choix de société
une société de travail et de mérite face
à une société je cite un gauchiste bobo
celle d'une société sans travail et sans
effort est-ce qu'il a raison le ministre
de l'Intérieur de présenter les débats
comme ça oui moi je suis parfaitement en
accord avec lui et je suis issu de la
culture pardonnez-moi durant même temps
je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans le cadre
des retraites on est face à une
situation qui est une situation
extrêmement claire à savoir que on a un
déficit on emprunte déjà pour combler ce
déficit ce déficit va se creuser et donc
il nous faut collectivement travailler
un peu plus longtemps c'est pas facile à
dire ça fait plaisir à personne ça me
fait pas plaisir à moi moi je me lève
pas le matin en me disant super je vais
voter une réforme des retraites mais
c'est un état de fait ce qui ne
n'empêche pas de réfléchir et c'est ce
que va faire Olivier du soft dans le
cadre des Assises du travail sur comment
est-ce qu'on améliore les conditions de
travail comment est-ce qu'on fait après
les retraites c'est bien ça c'est deux
choses le mode de management moi je
crois qu'il y a davantage une crise du
salariat qu'une crise du travail il faut
faire la différence entre l'emploi et le
travail c'est pas exactement la même
chose comment est-ce qu'on construit les
carrières professionnelles par exemple
dans la fonction publique l'un n'empêche
pas l'eau alors on va y venir sur les
sur les solutions mais le diagnostic je
commence par les politiques Farida moine
bon c'est pas l'aliénation absolue dans
le pays le travail c'est les enquêtes ne
disent pas ça qui soit moins central
moins important dans la vie des Français
vous vous en réjouissez ou vous le délai
je pense que les Français les françaises
veulent travailler autrement et mieux
travailler tout simplement ils veulent
travailler autrement ils veulent vous
savez le travail fait partie de la vie
bien entendu mais ils sont les Français
ont conscients qu'il faut partager le
travail parce que il y en a mais il faut
le partager et sont aussi conscients
qu'il y a dans la vie un temps pour le
travail mais un temps pour le reste un
temps ce qu'on appelle un temps libre
donc ce temps libre il peut être utilisé
pour faire autre chose et le confinement
elle a bien montré il faut continuer à
accompagner ce mouvement vous pensez
écoutez je pense que en tout cas c'est
de vision qui qui
s'affrontent quelque part mais oui les
Français les Français ont d'ailleurs le
disent clairement puisque 80% des
Français et des Français sont contre la
réforme de la retraite ils ne veulent
pas travailler jusqu'à 64 ans 93% des
actifs ne veulent pas travailler jusqu'à
64 ans donc on voit bien que l'opinion
et les Français sont pas d'accord avec
cette réforme Dominique MEDA votre
diagnostic on va parler des conditions
de travail parce que ça c'est vraiment
votre sujet et elles sont pas bonnes les
enquêtes le montrent mais sur la place
dans nos vies qu'elle travaille elle a
vraiment beaucoup changé pas du tout je
suis en totale désaccord avec ce que
vous dites depuis tout à l'heure moi ça
c'est la Fondation Jean Jaurès on va
laisser après Jérémy
pelletieres sur les valeurs de européens
depuis les années 90 alors qu'est-ce
qu'on voit je dirais un pour résumer que
on a une accentuation des tendances
antérieures mais rien de plus c'est à
dire le travail reste important ce
chiffre de passer de 60 à 24 c'est
possible et il faudra avoir d'autres
points je crois que ça suffit pas
d'avoir comme ça un point ce qu'on voit
depuis 30 ans c'est que le travail est
très important mais ce qu'on voit aussi
je vous donne un chiffre de 1999 dans la
même enquête les Français étaient les
plus nombreux à dire que le travail
était très important et en même temps
ils étaient les plus nombreux 70% à dire
qu'ils souhaitaient que le travail
prenne moins de place pourquoi un les
conditions de travail trop mauvais c'est
à dire on a d'énormes attentes elles
viennent s'écraser sur les conditions de
travail sur la réalité des conditions de
travail deux des questions de
conciliation mauvaise vie familiale vie
professionnelle je vous donne un autre
chien 2003 on fait une très grosse
enquête avec l'INSEE et Linde et on dit
aux personnes alors est-ce que le
travail est plus important tout le reste
ils sont 3% à dire que le travail est
plus important que tout le reste ils
sont
66% à dire le travail est moins
important que d'autres choses vie
familiale vie professionnelle vie
sociale rien n'a changé donc le travail
bon il est toujours très important
est-ce qu'il y a une centralité du
travail nous avec mes collègues on
préfère parler de police centrisme des
valeurs c'est à dire le travail est
important mais il doit être à sa juste
place mon ajuste de la plupart la
question du télétravail et dans ceci je
me sens plus en accord avec le rapport
de l'instrumental qui est paru ce matin
c'est bizarre mais voilà
je pense que les choses n'ont pas tant
changé que ça et en effet ce qu'on voit
et là aussi c'est quelque chose qui
existe depuis 30 ans on a toute la série
des enquêtes les conditions de travail
françaises et européenne et ce qu'on
voit c'est que la France elle est
complètement en queue de peloton c'est
abominable donc le travail est devenu
intenable on va revenir intenable voilà
alors on va venir sur les conditions
mais déjà la place c'est votre enquête
Jérémy Pelletier Fondation Jean Jaurès
vous montrer qu'il y a des choses qu'on
accepte plus
de faire les journées à rallonge la vie
du cabinet d'affaires ou voilà vous
emmener l'ordinateur le week-end ça vous
l'observez vraiment ouais c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler finalement la dimension
sacrificielle du travail et peut-être
pour réagir aussi à ce qui a été dit
faut pas oublier qu'en fait la réforme
de retraite elle arrive quand même dans
un moment très particulier elle arrive
après à la crise sanitaire et en fait
c'est la première mobilisation depuis la
crise sanitaire depuis des confinements
nos vies elles ont été bouleversées
pendant ce moment pendant ce moment là
pendant cette parenthèse là et c'est
quoi l'élément qui a été le plus impacté
je crois dans ce grand moment finalement
de réinterrogations collective en fait
le travail c'est justement le travail
quelle place du travail dans ma vie et
ce que je veux rééquilibrer la place de
travail entre ma vie personnelle ma vie
familiale etc des préférences aussi
entre loisirs et argent vous dans votre
enquête vous dites 61 % des salariés
préfèrent désormais gagner moins
d'argent mais avoir plus de temps libre
c'est beaucoup ouais bien sûr ça a été
bouleversé l'élément moi je crois qui
est très important dans les années 80 et
90 parce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant vous demandez aux salariés
est-ce que la balance elle est
équilibrée entre ce que vous donnez au
travail est-ce que vous recevez du
travail en terme symbolique en termes de
reconnaissance financière reconnaissance
symbolique etc vous avez plus d'un actif
sur deux qui considère que la balance
elle est équilibrée en gros par rapport
à ce que je donne bon j'en reçois à peu
près l'équivalent donc ça va balancé
équilibrer vous poser la même question
aujourd'hui là pour le coup les salariés
français ont considérablement le
sentiment que la balance elle est
déséquilibrée et c'est en ça ou je pense
que c'est très intéressant la dimension
statutaire je dirais du travail elle
s'est délit parce qu'en gros les gens ne
sont plus prêts à donner autant par
rapport à ce qui est le travail
aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qu'il
ressemble aujourd'hui et là ça rejoint
je pense des éléments analysés par
Dominique MEDA je pense que le travail
il a perdu de sa substance une partie
aussi de son intérêt et nous on le voit
dans l'enquête il y a une part de
salarié très importante depuis la crise
notamment qui disent être touché par une
baisse de motivation baisse de
motivation dans leur vie d'une façon
générale mais baisse de motivation pour
retourner sur site pour retourner sur le
lieu de travail pourquoi tout simplement
parce que une partie de ce qu'est le
travail a perdu de son intérêt à perdre
du de sa substance du notamment à ce que
vous avez évoqué d'ailleurs des
processus de management dû aussi à ce
qu'on peut appeler la financiarisation
aussi de l'économie il y a une part du
travail en fait qui est moins
intéressant et en gros pourquoi
aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui est
intéressant quand vous interrogez les
jeunes aujourd'hui
leur demander est-ce que gagner suppose
de faire des sacrifices est-ce que il
faut souffrir pour réussir vous avez
encore une majorité de la population
française qui est OK avec cette phrase
les jeunes pour le coup ils disent non
non c'est pas parce que je souffre que
je vais réussir en tout cas je peux
réussir sans souffrir et donc
effectivement ce no pain no gain là pour
le coup je pense que sanitaire elle a
considérablement rééquilibré bouleverser
les choses crise sanitaire et question
générationnelle peut-être la génération
Y dont on parle beaucoup on va entendre
quelques travailleurs quelques salariés
place du travail qualité de vie au
travail sens du travail et télétravail
ce sont des témoignages sur le terrain
recueillis par Baptiste guichardtier
regarde
accordez de moins en moins d'importance
à son travail un sentiment de plus en
plus partagé chez les Français ces
repositionner ce qui est important les
gens sont moins engagés et privilégier
plutôt leur vie personnelle à leur vie
professionnelle la vie professionnelle
n'est plus une fin en soi pour beaucoup
de gens tout simplement pour moi
sentimentale et physique en fait ça a
des répercussions au quotidien plus de
confort dans son emploi donc
illustration dans cette brasserie
parisienne David Tamayo la dérive depuis
plus d'un an
lui constate un sérieux changement lors
des recrutements le remarque aussi qu'on
recrute les personnes qui veulent le
week-end ils veulent leur soirée tout ça
dans la restauration c'est très
compliqué donc moi quand j'ai un jeune
qui me demande du boulot je lui demande
tout de suite disponible quand il me dit
que il peut pas travailler le soir et
les week-ends tout de suite non le
rapport au travail a donc changé mais
comment l'expliquer en toile de fond le
covid-19 l'épidémie aurait façonné les
pratiques au bureau en témoignent
notamment la demande croissante de
télétravail aujourd'hui 34% des actifs
sont concernés c'est 71% chez les cadres
plus présent pour amener les enfants à
l'école aller les chercher et il a
justement changé de travail et c'était
dans ces conditions je trouve qu'on peut
être plus productif aussi se centrer
puis est embêté par la collègue qui
passe sa tête le bureau etc moi je sais
que personnellement je fais beaucoup
plus vite
des nouvelles pratiques qui interrogent
dans les rues de Pont-Audemer en
Normandie c'est le cas de Charles Donati
désormais à la retraite
le travail était prépondérant primordial
sur sur une personnelle maintenant je
pense que les jeunes générations sont
plus soucieuses dans certaines équilibre
entre la vie performance professionnelle
et la vie perso selon l'Institut Jean
Jaurès la prise de distance croissante
entre les Français et leur travail ne
seraient pas synonyme de moindre
investissement dans leur tâches
voilà télétravail ne veut pas dire
moindre investissement Dominique MEDA ah
ça on peut ajouter aussi qu'il y a quand
même moins de chômage oui ça veut dire
qu'on peut aussi peut-être facilement un
peu plus choisir quand il y a des
besoins recrutement notamment on peut se
dire que voilà on a un peu de liberté
mais vous voyez bien que dans le
reportage il y a plein de choses qui
sont mélangées on parle de perte de
motivation de paresse de flemme et puis
après de télétravail je pense que ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que ça fait bien
bien longtemps que les gens tentent de
concilier vie professionnelle et vie et
vie familiale on peut dire aussi que ça
fait bien longtemps que monde dans la
société le désir de conciliation de
travailler mieux etc ça fait très
longtemps je me souviens d'une enquête
publiée en 1975 au Centre d'études de
l'emploi ou déjà on dit ah les jeunes
veulent plus bosser donc voilà chaque
fois on dit que les jeunes veulent plus
bosser c'est c'est complètement faux il
nous dans les enquêtes qu'on a fait on a
vu qu'au contraire les jeunes avaient
des attentes encore plus intenses que
que les autres attention aux idées
reçues et donc autant et donc autant le
télétravail en effet c'est quelque chose
de très important ça ça a changé des
choses mais le reste non c'est pas vrai
qu'on est devenu moins motivé plus
paresseux etc ça je crois pas du tout
mode région oui je bombe complètement
dans le sens moi je sais pas si je suis
encore jeune mais en tout cas étant de
la génération 90 je suis pas très
vieille et je pense que il est faux de
dire que les jeunes sera devenu
fainéants qui n'auraient pu envie de
travailler c'est pas vrai c'est pas
parce que le rapport au travail a changé
qu'on a pu le goût de l'effort et qu'on
plus le goût du travail je vais aussi
revenir sur la question du télétravail
pour l'avoir vécu moi-même en tant
qu'employé à l'époque pendant la période
covid à titre personnel j'en ai beaucoup
souffert et je pense qu'on a été
nombreux dans ce cas là parce que le
travail c'est aussi la socialisation
professionnelle que ça embarque c'est
aussi le sentiment d'appartenir à un
collectif alors les conditions du
travail ont changé bien mais je pense
qu'il faut faire attention à ça et que
cette notion de collectif elle est
extrêmement importante on peut aimer le
travail pour l'activité en tant que tel
bien sûr et puis ensuite il y a un
dernier point qui me semble absolument
primordial et qu'on aborde pas assez
c'est comment l'ascension
professionnelle elle est égale à
l'ascenseur social et aujourd'hui
peut-être moins qu'il y a 30 ou 40 ans
mais je laisserai les professionnels en
parler moi j'ai le sentiment que
l'ascension professionnelle ne permet
pas ne permet plus comme avant
l'ascenseur social et c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel on doit
travailler parce que derrière la notion
de travail il y a la notion de
reconnaissance et c'est ce que je disais
en début d'émission la nécessité de
travailler sur des parcours
professionnels par exemple pour les
enseignants alors c'est pas un milieu
que je connais très bien aujourd'hui
vous rentrez enseignant à 20 et quelques
années vous avez de bonnes chances de le
rester toute votre vie je crois que ça
c'est des modèles qui aujourd'hui ne
sont plus acceptés et plus alors on va
essayer de voir les solutions dans un
instant parce qu'on entend à nouveau
parler de se mettre de 4 jours de compte
épargne temps qui reviendraient donc
est-ce que c'est ça correspond au
diagnostic sur les conditions de travail
Victor Castanet vous vous avez rencontré
beaucoup beaucoup de personnels des
EHPAD on savait qu'il y avait du burn
out parfois du bord out c'est l'ennui au
travail on découvre maintenant j'ai
découvert ça le Brown out c'est la perte
de sens à quoi je sers je ne comprends
pas je ne comprends pas le sens de mon
travail je me sens dévalorisé parce que
je n'ai plus aucune forme de
d'explication sur mon utilité moi c'est
ce que j'ai constaté tout au long de mon
enquête dans tous les métiers du soin
d'ailleurs
c'est que il y a pas si vous voulez moi
je vois pas des gens qui dont le rapport
au travail a changé je vois des gens qui
ne trouvent plus de sens à leur travail
quand vous êtes par exemple
aide-soignante ou auxiliaire de vie en
EHPAD le sens de votre travail c'est
quoi c'est une relationnel c'est en gros
le temps que vous pouvez passer avec une
personne âgée est-ce que vous pouvez lui
apporter en soins on affection en
tendresse en discussion ce temps-là
elles ne l'ont plus tout ce qu'elles
font et chronométré parce qu'il manque
de soignants donc elles n'ont même pu le
temps de faire convenablement les tâches
de soins donc alors prendre le temps de
discuter et d'avoir ce relationnel c'est
impossible donc elle elles ont perdu le
sens de leur travail et combien mais
c'est des centaines de personnes que qui
j'ai parlé qui me racontent qu'elles ont
été dégoûtées de leur travail ces
dernières années parce que les
conditions de travail ce sont dégradées
et c'est vrai pour les postes de
soignants et d'auxiliaires de vie mais
c'est la même chose pour les directeurs
d'établissements qu'est-ce qu'il me
raconte les cadres aussi les cadres les
directeurs chez ORPEA mais ailleurs
c'est que avant quand directeur
d’établissements vous gériez votre
personnel c'est vous qui embauchiez
recrutez etc votre budget etc c'est vous
qui dirigez votre établissement chez
ORPEA chez d'autres groupes tout était
dirigé par des applications ils avaient
plus aucune marge de manœuvre c'est une
application qui leur disait voilà tu as
droit à tant de protection pour tes
résidences à droite tant de personnel
celui-là tu vas pas pouvoir l'embaucher
donc c'était devenu des pions et donc
que ça soit les soignants ou les cadres
tous avaient une perte de sens quotidien
dans leur travail c'est ça c'est la
segmentation des tâches le modèle
libéral qu'on introduit dans chaque
activité c'est c'est quelque chose que
vous observez depuis longtemps tout à
fait et vous reprenez exactement les
termes qu'emploie les personnes que nous
on a pu interroger c'est-à-dire on est
on est que des pions on nous demande
jamais notre avis et quand vous regardez
l'enquête européenne sur les conditions
de travail donc soit en 71
000 personnes qui ont été interviewées
très très grosses en 2021 la très grosse
enquête et qui a des vagues tous tous
les cinq ans donc on peut regarder
l'évolution on peut regarder ça dans
tous les sens ce qu'on voit c'est que en
effet la France elle est terriblement
mal placée de ce point de vue alors à la
fois pour tout ce qui est des
contraintes physiques mais aussi des
contraintes psychiques de la
reconnaissance comme on le disait tout à
l'heure et qu'il y a en effet un
problème je crois qu'on l'a dit avec le
management on a un management qui ne
convient pas et nous dans les enquêtes
que l'on que l'on a faite on voit bien
que on ce qu'on reproche c'est un
management sont des sur le diplôme un
management scolaire avec des gens qui
arrivent qui connaissent rien à la à la
réalité du travail qui est fait et des
gens je me souviens d'une dame qu'on
interviewée qui disait comment
voulez-vous que mon manager me
reconnaisse puisqu'ils ne connaît pas
mon travail ça veut dire qu'il se
connaît pas les résistances qui te code
donc là on a je crois qu'on peut dire
qu'on a en France une crise du travail
et si je reprends l'argumentation que
j'ai développé en effet dans cette
chronique ça consistait à dire que c'est
une véritable provocation de faire une
réforme des retraites dans sur cet état
absolument fou de du travail en France
et qu'il aurait fallu semble-t-il si je
puis me permettre d'abord faire un geste
vers les personnes dire ok on a compris
qu'il y a une crise du travail on va
essayer de régler ça on vous a compris
et ensuite d'autant que quand même le
covid sur ce la question c'est c'est pas
possible je vais rebondir sur ce que
vous dites et ça rejoint ce que je
disais sur la nécessité d'être en
capacité de s'élever socialement de
s'élever dans l'entreprise en vous
donnant un exemple très personnel quand
je suis rentré dans le monde du travail
j'étais chez EDF mon manager il avait
commencé à 16 ou 17 ans en tant que
technicien sur une centrale nucléaire il
avait monté les échelons et puis il
était mon N+1 ce qui faisait qu'on le
respectait notamment au-delà de toutes
ces autres qualités c'est qu'il savait
précisément de quoi le technicien lui
parlait quand il y avait un problème sur
la pompe machin ça c'est un modèle à mon
avis qu'il faut qu'on a un peu perdu et
qu'il faut réussir à retravailler sur la
question du management je vais vous
donner un deuxième exemple quand je suis
encore une fois rentrée dans mon
entreprise j'avais mon bureau partager
avec une ou collègues bon à la fin huit
ans plus tard non seulement j'avais plus
mon bureau j'avais plus ma pièce mais on
était dans ce qu'on appelle le flex
office le flex office c'est un grand
espace partagé pour 30 ou 40 personnes
ou votre bureau n'est pas le vôtre
c'est-à-dire que vous changez tous les
jours donc vous n'avez plus de repères
il y a un gain foncier pour l'entreprise
qui est évident mais vous n'avez plus la
petite photo de votre enfant ou de votre
ami qui est sur votre bureau qui
finalement fait que vous vous sentez un
petit peu chez vous c'est intéressant
mais parce que précisément je pense que
la réforme des retraites qu'on mène
n'est pas en opposition avec cette
réflexion là et que la réforme des
retraites est une réforme d'urgence là
où à mon avis sur ces questions ça
demande vraiment de prendre le temps de
la beaucoup de gens qui pensent c'est
très start-up nation et c'est plutôt
moi je pense qu'il faut faire peut-être
qu'il y a des gens qui sont très bien
mais mais à mon avis ça veut dire que
voilà il y a des consensus possibles
Jérémy Pelletier Chris du travail crise
du management là ça vous retrouvez ça
dans votre oui bien sûr et ce qui est
intéressant vous parliez du personnel
soignant durant la crise sanitaire on
avait interrogé les infirmiers les
infirmières on faisait des petits coups
de sombre comme ça pour savoir comment
ça se passait dans les hôpitaux donc on
leur demandait dans un certain nombre de
d'hôpitaux comment ça se passe le
travail ça doit être difficile
d'affirmière elle vous disait ouais
c'est difficile parce qu'on a une charge
importante mais vous savez c'est pas mal
parce qu'on a mis les administratifs en
télétravail je dis ah bon ça veut dire
quoi ça me mette les administratifs en
télétravail mais en fait tous les gens
qui en gros nous pompent tous les jours
avec des process avec des tableaux Excel
avec en gros des trucs sur lesquels en
fait nous on était pas formés au départ
et on a pas signé pour ça quand on est
devenu infirmière enfermé bah tous ces
gens là on les a mis en télétravail et
donc du jour au lendemain on s'est
retrouvé entre gens finalement qui
savent entre gens qui ont entre
guillemets les mains dans le cambouis et
donc du jour au lendemain finalement
elles ont retrouvé et ça c'est hyper
intéressant je dis elle parce que
c'était beaucoup de femmes pour le coup
du sang effectivement à leur travail
donc ça c'est un premier un premier
élément il y a un élément je pense qui
est très important dans notre débat
c'est que on peut pas analyser
effectivement ce qui est devenu le
travail sans parler d'intensification du
travail en fait ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'au cours des 30 dernières années par
rapport à ce que dit Dominique Méda la
productivité l'efficience les cadences
en fait au travail dans toutes les
professions ce sont accélérées à cause
aussi notamment du numérique donc les
cadences le rythme du travail le rythme
de ce que vous faites etc tout ça c'est
accéléré résultat vous avez et c'est
aussi le son de notre étude tout un tas
d'actifs en fait qui se disent fatigués
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle en
effet vous avez une partie des salariés
qui disent je veux prendre maintenant de
la distance je veux rééquilibrer parce
qu'en fait je suis fatigué lié notamment
à ces condenses là et à ce rythme là qui
s'est accéléré et un dernier élément on
parle beaucoup de pénibilité dans les
années 80-90 vous demandez aux actifs
français est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'exercer un travail pénible
vous avez environ 15% des actifs qui
considèrent que oui ou les interrogez
aujourd'hui on est passé à quasiment 30%
donc intensification du travail plus
grande part de salariés qui disent
exercer un travail pénible et c'est là
où par rapport à la réforme de retraite
je crois qu'il y a une une erreur de
fait c'est que le débat sur le travail
c'était un préalable à tout c'était un
préalable à tout et notamment le débat
sur la question de la pénibilité c'était
un préalable essentiel central à toute
réforme des retraites quelle que soit
d'ailleurs la modalités qui a une loi
travail une loi emploi qui arrive si
voilà c'est normalement quelque soit
d'ailleurs vote ou pas votre sur les
retraites c'est prévu il y aura un
agenda législatif après une loi travail
qui prendra en compte les questions
pénibilité au travail la question des
seniors également mais aussi et c'est
nouveau peut-être la réduction pas la
réduction de temps de travail mais les
35 heures sur quatre jours l'idée est
relancée elle sera expérimentée est-ce
que ce sont des pistes que la nuque
pourrait soutenir tout dépend ce qu'il y
a dans le texte encore une fois mais
bien entendu nous on soutient le fait
que justement cette réforme aurait dû
passer après la première des choses on
aurait dû se poser la question qu'est-ce
que le travail comment les Français les
françaises veulent travailler et les
assises parce que apparemment il y a des
assises emploi travail qui vont avoir
lieu ces assis là elles pas pu avoir
lieu maintenant et pas après le débat
sur la retraite c'est maintenant parce
que c'est lié c'est lié l'emploi à la
retraite etc tout ça c'est lié c'est lié
pourquoi parce que les Français en fait
ce qu'ils veulent c'est travailler donc
moi je rejoins c'est pas des fainéants
loin de là ils veulent travailler mais
ils veulent travailler mieux travailler
avec des conditions de travail correctes
parce que leurs conditions de travail
sont dégradées je vais prendre un
exemple si la semaine les quatre jours
soyons concrets la semaine proposé en
même temps que la réforme des retraites
ça aurait été plus acceptable à vos yeux
il aurait non il aurait pu en fait on
aurait dû se poser la question de
justement de ce qu'est le travail et
comment les Français les Françaises
voient le travail et considèrent le
travail c'est ça quel sens parce que on
l'a tous dit on l'a tous vu que les
Français françaises veulent donner du
sens du sens au travail et aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui manque il manque ce sens je
suis dans la fonction avant d'être
député c'était dans la fonction publique
territoriale
et on a vu arriver nous avant dans les
années quand j'ai commencé on n'avait
pas ce mot de manager de de résultat etc
on l'avait pas le nous ce qu'on devait
faire le sens de notre travail c'était
de rendre service en fait d'être dans le
service public et rendre service au
public ça c'était notre sens de travail
et moi j'ai vu mes collègues au fur et à
mesure en fait se mettre en arrêt même
chez les quatre se mettre en arrêt
maladie parce que justement ils ne
retrouvait plus ça on leur disait il y a
qu'à il faut faire et c'est comme ça peu
importe qui on avait en face qu'à
l'usager on avait en face et ça c'est
probable alors il y a un diagnostic
partagé et voilà je le souligne
également dans les rangs de la majorité
qu'est-ce qu'on fait redonner du sens
c'est pas quelque chose d'évident ça se
traduit pas forcément dans un plan de
loi comment comment on s'y prend
concrètement il y a quelques pistes ce
compte d'épargne tant pour pouvoir au
fond décider de monnayer ou de garder
des RTT de les étaler la semaine des
quatre jours alors certains veulent
réduire le temps de travail d'autres
faire 35 heures en quatre jours ce sont
des pistes est-ce qu'elles sont
utile efficace mais pardonnez-moi moi je
vois peut-être je vis à quelque chose
que j'ai pas compris hein je veux
absolument pas le rapport entre régler
la crise du travail et faire passer une
URSSAF à 4 jours voilà j'ai pas compris
en revanche c'est le site qui a été
choisi pour l'expérimentation dans les
services publics par Gabriel je vois
absolument pas parce que on peut tout à
fait sur 4 jours intensifier le travail
ou bien on peut moins travailler payer
plus payer moins voilà donc là je
comprends pas en revanche je sais pas si
vous avez vu il y a un rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui est sorti en
décembre 2022 là sur le compte de
prévention qui tire un bilan qui tire à
boulet rouge sur la réforme qui a été
faite en 2017 qui a enlevé des critères
de pénibilité et non mais c'est très
intéressant cette critique parce que ce
que dit la Cour des comptes c'est que en
fait il y a même plus d'incitation des
entreprises à améliorer les conditions
de travail et donc si on regarde bien
les choses qu'est-ce qui nous disent ils
nous disent mais reprenez regardez par
exemple toutes les aides que vous donnez
aux entreprises et mettez les sous
conditions
et sur la pénibilité et rendez ce compte
incitatif pour que les entreprises
s'occupent enfin des conditions de
travail de leur salarié il y a
énormément c'est vrai de sujets autour
de ces critères qui ont été supprimés
par le gouvernement qui d'après les
entreprises étaient trop compliquées une
usine à gaz qu'est ce que vous allez
faire précisément à sa place il y a déjà
ce qui est inclus dans la réforme des
retraites donc on retravaille les
critères de pénibilité et ensuite moi
j'ai pas de boule de cristal je peux pas
vous dire ce qui se passera dans les
deux prochaines semaines mais ce qui est
certain c'est que la question la
pénibilité elle doit faire partie
intégrante des débats qu'on aura à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui aura
ensuite comment de concrètement il y
avait des critères charges lourdes
produits chimiques travail de nuit
est-ce qu'il faut les remettre ces
critères ou est-ce que il faut tout
simplement dire quand on travaille dans
telle branche c'est forcément pénible et
puis hop vous à partir du moment où vous
avez un métier vous n'avez plus rien à
prouver vous fermez faut se fermer il
faut se faire
mais aucune porte il y a besoin de
remettre des critères il faut remettre
des critères il faut le faire évidemment
en lien avec les branches je pense pas
que le choix soit aussi manichéen c'est
pas forcément tout l'un ou tout l'autre
juste pour terminer un peu la allez-y
peut-être ma dernière prise de parole ce
que je retiens de me faire on est tous
d'accord pour dire que le travail
demeure centrale dans la place de la vie
d'une immense majorité des Français et
que pour autant on a un enjeu majeur de
par les questions de management de par
les questions de formation de
d'humaniser le travail de re-humaniser
le travail
la réforme des retraites nous on
l'assume pleinement et elle est pas
antinomique avec cette question là elle
vient en plus le fait de réfléchir à
l'évolution de travail ne change rien au
déficit qu'on aura dans la caisse et
c'est un peu ce que je reproche à une
partie de la nupesse et je pense ce qui
explique qu'une partie des électeurs qui
étaient avant des électeurs de gauche
notamment issus des classes ouvrières ce
sont détournées des parties de gauche
c'est qu'on a eu le sentiment que vous
avez peu à peu délaissé la question du
travail l'enjeu du travail au profit des
aides sociales
gros débat pour conclure ouvrir cette
question là en fin de débat
très bien et c'est pourtant il est pas
de mon bord politique François Ruffin
qui a écrit un livre qui s'appelle je
vous écris du fruit il y a quelques mois
et qui va bien et qu'il en parle en
expliquant ce qu'il a entendu sur le
terrain et des gens qui lui disaient
finalement moi j'aime le travail donc je
peux pas voter à gauche responsable de
la système
moi j'ai une petite question pour
terminer je voudrais qu'on termine avec
le travail est-ce que vous pensez que le
slogan de Nicolas Sarkozy travaillait
plus pour gagner plus ça passerait
encore aujourd'hui ou pas non moi je
crois pas d'une part parce qu'on voit
que effectivement sur l'évolution entre
les années 80-90 et aujourd'hui pour le
coup on a quand même un changement de
hiérarchie et de préoccupation de
hiérarchie de valeur par ailleurs
finalement vous avez tout un tas de
salariés à qui on a promis le travailler
plus pour gagner plus mais en fait qui
n'en ont pas vu la couleur
hiérarchie de valeur mais c'est aussi un
slogan tout simplement qui de toute
façon ne susciterait plus la confiance
parce qu'en fait beaucoup de salariés
ont cru et en fait ne l'ont pas obtenu
je vais donner le enfin à Dominique
Médard la reconnaissance la valorisation
le sens traduit comme moi je pense qu'en
effet les gens n'adopteraient plus ce
slogan si le travail reste tel qu'il est
si le travail devient une vallée de une
vallée de miel et de lait alors
peut-être qu'ils voudront travailler
voilà juste rajouter quelque chose vous
avez parlé de cela mais le le
du slogan en fait de Monsieur Darmanin
qui disait que le travail n'est pas une
maladie par contre le travail
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est fait tel qu'il
organisé il rend les gens malades il
peut rendre les gens malades alors
certains salariés ont précisé
merci c'était très intéressant merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir débattu de ce
sujet à la valeur travail le rapport au
travail sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Victor Castanet dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir l'économie avec Fanny
guinochet qui revient sur le rapport
alarmant de la Fondation Abbé Pierre sur
le mal logement Mario Stasi le président
de la lycra nous parlera du plan contre
le racisme
vous allez par Matignon cette semaine et
puis le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution votre historique au Sénat
Bourbon Express tout à l'heure elles
amont d'un Gava à tout à l'heure les
amis mais d'abord on va plonger dans
dans vos 10 nouveaux chapitres Victor
Castanet on croyait avoir tout lu sur le
scandale Europa le système frauduleux
les surfacturations du groupe auprès de
ses fournisseurs la maltraitance le
rationnement et on découvre les
intimidations les espions et les
pressions on voit cela dans l'invitation
de Baptiste guerrier-chartier et puis on
en parle juste après
si on vous invite Victor Castanet c'est
pour votre édition enrichie les
fossoyeurs une bombe médiatique qui
dénonçait la gestion désastreuse des
maisons de retraite hors pa un
électrochoc je pense que le regard de la
société a changé que les familles et les
médias sont plus vigilants encore sur
sur ces questions vous êtes journalistes
indépendants prient Albert Londres
l'année dernière pour la première
édition de cet ouvrage 170
000 exemplaires vendus mais cette
fois-ci vous y ajoutez 10 chapitres ou
vous expliquer les conséquences de cette
affaire autant dans la gouvernance que
dans les finances le service rhda
faisait appel là encore à des sociétés
d'intelligence économique et plus
précisément à des détectives privés pour
monter des dossiers sur certains
salariés notamment les salariés
syndiqués ce livre nous plonge dans un
nid de vipère dites-vous
interception de vos informations contre
feu des communicants même vous racontez
les pressions reçues du groupe ORPEA
juste avant l'apparition de votre
enquête
[Musique]
à l'époque ce coup des classes sème
d'ailleurs le trouble chez les
politiques nous allons
travailler et
allons informer de ce que nous avons
décidé mais certains vont encore plus
loin 70 députés signent une tribune dans
le journal Le Monde tous plaident pour
une commission d'enquête mais la
nouvelle déranger l'Élysée
ils ont donné l'impression de réagir
dites-vous mais ils ont tout fait pour
mettre le sujet sous le tapis
le système ORPEA est désormais entre les
mains des juges l'onde de choc n'est
donc toujours pas terminé Victor
Castanet vous êtes passionné par cette
sphère de la santé alors question
avez-vous le sentiment d'être devenu un
justicier dans ce domaine
réponse
juste ici est-ce que c'est comme ça que
vous voyez ou pas du tout non j'aime pas
ni le terme de justicier ni le terme de
journaliste militant moi effectivement
j'ai 200 sources qui ont participé à
cette enquête et je me sens une
responsabilité de porter leur voix et
surtout si vous voulez de mettre ce
sujet au cœur de l'actualité pour que
les choses changent véritablement parce
que si vous voulez on peut ne pas être
militant mais savoir que toutes les
questions de rapport de force et qu'en
gros pour que les politiques bougent il
faut effectivement maintenir ce sujet
dans l'actualité médiatique c'est le
seul moyen de les forcer à faire quelque
chose alors les choses elles ont quand
même bougé au moins un hors pa les
dirigeants ont été limogés la tête du
groupe privé est aujourd'hui sous le
coup d'une enquête il y a eu quand même
voilà aujourd'hui même une reprise de
contrôle par l'État on va en parler déjà
par rapport à la déflagration bien
au-delà d'ailleurs de européens il y a
des établissements publics aussi et des
établissements associatifs et beaucoup
de témoignages comment vous vous dites
tout cela c'est facile à porter vous
êtes fier ou c'est plus compliqué non
non c'est une fierté en tant que
journaliste et c'est une source de
satisfaction pour toutes les sources les
salariés les familles qui ont participé
à cette enquête et qui ont pris des
risques pour le faire et qui dans les
jours et les semaines précédents étaient
tremblotants avant la publication de ce
livre elles avaient peur des
représailles qu'elle pouvait subir et
elles avaient peur de sortir du bois
pour rien qui ne se passe rien comme
malheureusement parfois c'est le cas
quand on fait des enquêtes et donc quand
elle voit l'impact que leur témoignage
et les documents qu'elles ont apporté
ont pu produire sur la société française
qu'il y a pu avoir ces prises de
position politique c'est suite
judiciaire
ce suivi médiatique le fait que c'est
libérer la parole ouais c'est une fierté
pour toutes les personnes qui ont
participé à cette enquête le système
ORPEA c'est fini le système tel que je
le décris dans le livre c'est à dire
c'est un système d'optimisation des
coûts extrêmement brutal avec des
politiques de rationnement sur
l'alimentation sur les produits de santé
et surtout c'est ce qu'il faut bien
rappeler c'est un système de
détournement d'argent public
c'est-à-dire on a enlevé des postes de
soignants qui avaient été financés par
l'assurance maladie et on a enlevé une
partie des budgets qui étaient utilisés
pour les produits de santé on les
mettait dans les caisses du groupe donc
c'est quand même ça le sujet ça c'est
stoppé sur toutes les
irrégularités au niveau du droit du
travail les licenciements massifs pour
faute grave sans aucun motif les CDD
abusif la discrimination syndicale tout
ça a été stoppé et pourtant les
fournisseurs et ça ça m'a surpris
Hartman et bastide sont conservés pour
l'instant malgré la nouvelle direction
d'Orpea ouais c'est pour ça que si vous
voulez bien sûr que ça me surprend si
vous voulez le système a été stoppé
c'était ce système là qui entraînait les
maltraitances ayant encore évidemment
énormément de sujets au sein de ce
groupe il y a effectivement le fait que
les fournisseurs en produits de santé
Bastide et Hartmann cela même qui ont
participé au détournement d'argent
public les prestataires en service
informatique qui ont participé à des
systèmes de surfacturation cela reste
encore travail avec le groupe Orpa il y
a aussi des cas de dirigeants qui
faisaient partie de l'ancienne direction
qui sont encore en poste donc il y a
encore ces sujets et puis plus largement
si vous voulez ça améliorera pas
fondamentalement chez RPA mais dans les
autres groupes c'est pareil tant que ce
secteur n'aura pas retrouvé si vous
voulez son attractivité pour vis-à-vis
des familles et des soignants c'est ça
qui va dire des embauches des moyens
c'est 9 milliards le rapport Libaux 9
milliards sur 50 ça fait pas loin de 50
milliards et pour l'instant on les voit
pas venir la loi grand âge n'a pas été
annoncé elle sera peut-être d'ailleurs
encore reportée
vous croyez vous que malgré le choc
c'est quand même une déception immense
moi si vous voulez un an après on peut
se dire que la réponse gouvernementale
elle est pas à la hauteur il y a eu des
améliorations sur les contrôles il y a
eu des embauches de d'inspecteurs d'Ars
et il y a eu un renforcement des
contrôles et une changement de
philosophie donc ça c'est une bonne
chose ça va permettre peut-être si vous
voulez moi quand j'ai appris ça de la
bouche du ministre de l'autonomie
Jean-Christophe con que il y avait un
contrôle tous les tous les 20 ans je dis
mais comment c'est possible c'est-à-dire
laisser perdurer des situations de
dysfonctionnement pendant des décennies
de contrôler tous les établissements n'y
est pas encore donc il y a un changement
une amélioration sur les contrôles mais
c'est pas suffisant mais le sujet de
base qui est en gros il y en a qu'un
c'est le nombre de soignants et et ça
tant cura pas une réponse politique
gouvernementale forte il y aura pas de
changement et c'est un point important
et je pense que là il y a il y a un
problème même d'approche c'est que
Jean-Christophe combe explique en gros
ça sert à rien de mettre plus de moyens
parce que le secteur est pas attractif
donc on n'arrive pas à embaucher les
acteurs principaux de ce secteur pensent
l'inverse c'est-à-dire il pense que si
l'État mais les moyens revalorisent les
salaires et dit on va financer
maintenant 8 soignants et animateurs
pour 10 résidents
vont venir qui a envie de travailler
dans ces conditions-là petite réaction
quand même à la à la reprise de contrôle
par l'État via la banque de la Caisse
des dépôts de l'état de d'Orpea c'est
une forme d'ailleurs de nationalisation
quasiment est-ce que c'est bienvenu je
sais pas comment dire ça si c'est une
semi-nationalisation en tout cas oui il
y a une prise de contrôle de la Caisse
des dépôts d'orpa et si vous voulez ce
que je peux dire on peut jamais savoir
on peut jamais dire tout va changer
maintenant qu'il y a la Caisse des
dépôts qui arrivent c'est impossible ce
qu'on peut dire en revanche c'est que
une des sources principales de la
maltraitance dans les établissements
c'est la pression financière dans les
dans le dans le privé il y avait avant
un certain nombre d'actionnaires qui
demandaient des niveaux de rentabilité
qui dépassait parfois les taux de marge
de 30%. avant loyer ce qu'a dit la
Caisse des Dépôts c'est qu'elle allait
baisser ses exigences de rentabilité et
demander plutôt passer de 25 c'était les
derniers taux à 20%. ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on baisse la pression
financière sur les EHPAD et les
cliniques d'ailleurs et que donc il y
aura a priori plus de soignants et plus
de produits de santé ça peut être que
mieux pour le secteur et je pense que si
ça peut marquer en gros la fin de l'air
des hyperprophies c'était un secteur
quand même on traite d'humain dépendant
et vulnérable et où on faisait des hyper
profits si on peut dire écoutez ce
secteur c'est un secteur particulier et
maintenant il y aura plus des taux de
marge aussi ahurissant peut-être que ça
peut enclencher un changement dans le
secteur alors dites-nous un mot sur les
pressions que vous avez subies ORPEA ni
d'espions c'est un peu ce qu'on peut
conclure quand on lit ces chapitres
supplémentaires vous avez eu des
détectives à vos trousses ce n'est pas
une mais deux sociétés d'intelligence
économique qui ont été positionner pour
contenir l'impact du livre oui j'ai
appris ça dans les mois précédents
l'enquête et j'ai eu encore de nouveaux
éléments après publication c'est
qu'effectivement quand j'envoie mes
questions à la direction générale de
leurs péage on voit plus de 60 questions
et c'est précises à ce moment-là ils
prennent conscience de l'ampleur de ce
qui va arriver je cite notamment le fait
que j'ai des éléments sur les fraudes à
l'argent public donc ils prennent peur
et à ce moment-là il y a un certain
nombre de sociétés d'intelligence
économiques qui sont missionnées pour
obtenir des informations sur moi sur le
contenu du livre qui vont essayer de se
procurer et d'identifier mes sources
donc c'est évidemment une source
d'inquiétude pour moi et pour la presse
en général c'est à dire de quoi sont
capables certaines sociétés cotées en
bourse et comment on utilise les
sociétés d'intelligence économique qui
font à la fois des choses tout à fait
régulières de la veille économique et
qui parfois ont certaines pratiques de
surveillance de filatures notamment sur
des très rapidement il nous reste peu de
temps vous parlez aussi des agences de
communication Image 7 pour ne pas la
nommer à Neo qui elle dément avoir
commandé un sondage opportun qui parlait
de la dépendance et du grand âge au
moment de la parution du livre il y a
même une histoire de sondage truquée
avec des faux comptes Twitter dont on
parle sur le plateau de Cyril Hanouna je
renvoie au lecteur l'Assemblée nationale
certains députés dans la majorité ont
fait pression sur un évidal pour qu'elle
n'obtienne pas de commission d'enquête
serait gêner le président de la
République qui rentrait en campagne
c'est comment le calendrier politique
est présidentiel a dicter un certain
nombre d'événements liés liés à ce sujet
à cette enquête effectivement j'ai
plusieurs témoignages et notamment celui
d'anni Vidal peu après la parution du
livre il y a 70 députés qui de tout bord
politique qui décident de signer une
tribune pour demander une commission
d'enquête parlementaire ce qui est le
cas pour tous les grands scandales
sanitaires d'ampleur pourquoi parce que
analyser que les députés analysent
de fond en comble le fonctionnement de
cette hors PA pour tirer des leçons non
pas judiciaires mais politiques sur ce
qu'il faut faire pour que ça n'arrive
plus moyen de
contraindreal et donc Annie Vidal tous
les courants politiques veulent signer
sauf la macronie et donc Annie Vidal
député à RM décide de signer et
effectivement elle va être violemment
prise à partie par un certain nombre de
ses députés de ses collègues députés de
la majorité présidentielle qui vont lui
dire que elle agit contre le président
de la République elle a plus rien à
faire dans le parti et pourquoi ils
pensent ça c'est parce que pour un
certain nombre de membres de la de la
macronie Emmanuel Macron n'a pas de
bilan sur le sujet de la dépendance il a
plusieurs fois promis nous à grand âge
en 2018 en 2020 il a sans cesse repoussé
et on peut imaginer que si elle avait
été mise en place quelques années plus
tôt peut-être un certain nombre de
dérives auraient pu être stoppé plutôt
voilà excès prudence ou véritable
pression les fossoyeurs c'est l'édition
augmentée chez Fay
[Applaudissements]
constitution sauf que les deux chambres
n'ont pas adopté exactement le même
texte non regardez à l'image l'assemblée
à adopter 7 versions la loi garantit
l'effectivité légale accès aux droits à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
au Sénat ça devient la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse un droit pour les députés une
liberté pour les sénateurs on peut
clairement dire que la version du Sénat
est moins contraignante elle elle mérite
d'exister puis elle a le mérite d'avoir
été adopté par des élus qu'on dit plus
conservateurs alors à la manœuvre il y
avait un sénateur de droite Philippe Bas
c'est lui qui a réécrit le texte de
l'Assemblée il a pesé chaque mot et il
l'a dit lui il pense pas que l'IVG soit
vraiment menacé en France mais à la fin
de sa prise de parole il a quand même
admis cela
qui vient de la je ne vois pas pourquoi
nous nous priveions de l'avantage
d'avoir inscrit dans le marbre de la
Constitution une liberté qui est déjà
reconnue comme une liberté de rang
constitutionnelle par le Conseil
constitutionnel et cela depuis plus de
20 ans une liberté d'ailleurs à laquelle
nous sommes tous profondément attachés
il a travaillé au cabinet de Simone Veil
il ne voulait pas qu'on considère qu'il
était opposé à l'avortement on se
retrouve donc avec deux textes qu'on à
peu près le même objectif mais pas les
mêmes rédactions alors qu'est-ce qui va
se passer maintenant quel est quelle est
l'avenir de cette loi alors normalement
si les deux assemblées votent dans les
mêmes termes une proposition loi donc il
faudrait quand même qu'elle revienne ici
à l'Assemblée qu'elles soient adoptée et
bien cette proposition de loi elle peut
être soumise à référendum il reste au
président de la République de prendre un
décret mais c'est pas l'objectif de
Mathilde panot c'est la présidente des
insoumis c'est elle qui avait défendu la
proposition de loi ici à l'Assemblée
elle nous explique pourquoi un
référendum elle n'en veut pas
en cas de référendum je suis absolument
persuadé que nous gagnerions se
référendum 9 Français sur 10 sont
favorables à ce qu'on protège ce droit
dans notre norme suprême mais cela
libéré une parole antichois extrêmement
forte qui je crois serait très
dommageable pour toute les femmes de ce
pays et notamment les petites filles de
ce pays donc vous vous voulez pas de
référendum c'est un projet de loi du
gouvernement et un congrès la réunion
des députés des sénateurs pour le vote
oui et le vote du sénay hier montre que
nous pourrions avoir facilement une
majorité sur cette question là voilà
c'est l'autre solution c'est que le
gouvernement fasse un texte de loi le
fasse adopté par les trois cinquième du
Congrès les élus des deux chambres ont
envoyé un signal en ce sens maintenant
c'est au gouvernement de répondre Simone
veille sur cette inscription j'en suis
sûr merci beaucoup Elsa Mario on
enchaîne avec vous alors vous vouliez
revenir sur ce plan qui a annoncé la
première ministre sur sur la lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme oui
Myriam et je reviendrai plus
particulièrement sur une des 80 à mesure
car nous avons en effet pu pousser une
mesure juridique permettant d'envisager
une action efficace oui Myriam ça y est
le temps de l'exception où l'on
considère que le raciste n'est pas un
délinquant de droit commun mais qui doit
bénéficier des protections procédurales
particulières réservées aux journalistes
et bien ce temps touche à sa fin mais
rien alors la lycra pesée mais on
comprend pas forcément très bien il y a
une loi contre le racisme aujourd'hui et
la même fêté ses 50 ans elle est pas
efficace pas inefficace Myriam mais elle
conserve une ambiguïté liée au fait
qu'elle fut inscrite en 72 dans la loi
de 1880 sur la liberté de la presse
comme l'avait été la précédente loi
Marchando de 1939 le délire raciste ou
antisémite a donc été pensé dans le cas
d'une loi de liberté appréhendée comme
une opinion dont il faut étudier
scrupuleusement les contours les
conditions dénonciation les intentions
des auteurs afin de ne pas déroger au
régime de liberté d'expression qui
prévaut dans notre démocratie alors il
faut expliquer pour vous il n'y a pas
d'environnement juridique favorable pour
lutter contre le délit de racisme les
juges font preuve d'une extrême prudence
et il ne faudrait pas en effet avoir à
redouter un procès dès lors que l'on
s'exprime sur l'un de ces sujets
fondamentaux qui divise l'opinion que ce
soit la nation l'immigration l'identité
mais ma chère Myriam vous allez me dire
que l'injure ou la formation mais oui la
diffamation appartiennent à un autre
registre et vous avez raison et vous
avez raison et c'est toute la difficulté
et l'ambiguïté des délits dont la lycra
demande depuis des années qu'il soit
sorti de la loi de 1881 pour être versé
dans le droit commun il faut en finir
avec cette situation qui profite à des
délinquants professionnels tels câlin
Soral Hervé rissen ou encore Dieudonné
M'Bala M'Bala devenu expert pour
échapper aux amandes et aux peines
d'emprisonnement est-ce que vous avez
obtenu gain de cause ou pas est-ce que
le plan a intégré la mesure portée par
la lycra presque pas tout en pas tout à
fait encore Myriam mais nous sommes sur
la bonne voie alors j'ai fait le du
gouvernement veut permettre l'émission
d'un mandat d'arrêt en cas d'infraction
grave à caractère raciste ou antisémite
ce qui signifie que l'arsenal de
sanction contre ce délinquant raciste et
potentiellement renforcé et que le
chemin entre lui la police et la prison
et sur le point d'être considérablement
raccourci donc c'est pas fait encore
c'est ça un plan demeure un plan il ne
fait qu’énoncer de grandes lignes
directrices c'est important décliner en
mesure dont il appartient aux
responsable politique autrement dit au
ministère de la Justice de s'en emparer
il reste donc à inscrire dans la loi
cette proposition qui vise à lutter
contre le sentiment d'impunité nous
cheminons vers la fin de l'exception
mais il reste des étapes importantes
pour que la loi soit effectivement
amendée et là il faudra un véritable
volontarisme politique et la lycra
soyons sûrs
ce qu'il vous faut une loi il est bien
passé ce soir merci Mario Fanny on
enchaîne
330 1000 c'est ça 330 000 SDF en France
c'est un chiffre dramatique et c'est
celui du rapport de la Fondation oui et
c'est dramatique parce que c'est le
c'est plus du double il y a 10 ans donc
c'est vraiment un chiffre qui s'aggrave
alors sachant que dans ce chiffre il
faut bien le préciser il y a à la fois
les sans-abri les gens qui n'ont pas du
tout de toi et puis il y a les SDF qui
sont sans domicile fixe donc qui peuvent
être dans des centres d'hébergement des
hôtels de fortune et elle intègre aussi
dans ce dans cette comptabilité les
personnes qui sont dans des bidonvilles
les demandeurs d'asile etc mais il
n'empêche on se souvient que Emmanuel
Macron au début sa première grande
promesse personne dans son objectif
c'était voilà plus personne dans la rue
on en est loin on en est très très loin
et en plus la Fondation Abbé Pierre
quand elle regarde et qu'elle met les
gens qui ont un toit mais qui ne
correspond pas au minimum qu'elle soit
trop petit soit vous avez pas de cuisine
ou très peu pas de chauffage pas de
toilette et bien on arrive à 4 millions
de personnes en France qui sont mal
logés quelle explication alors la hausse
découle la hausse des prix mais aussi
des prix de l'immobilier qui ont
appauvri les ménages qui n'arrivent pas
à suivre les niveaux de de loyer
insoutenables mais ce qui est
préoccupant et c'est ce que montre le
rapport de cette année c'est que les
inégalités de logement et bien une fois
encore elles sont genre et c'est à dire
que les femmes en pâtissent beaucoup
plus parce que elles ont beaucoup plus
de mal à trouver un logement elles sont
moins bien payées elles ont des plus de
boulot de job en temps partiel donc des
contrats plus précaires évidemment pour
louer c'est beaucoup plus difficile
d'avoir un logement sable en plus quand
elle part du domicile parental ou même
familial et bien elle subissent plus le
déclassement résidentiel et la Fondation
Abbé Pierre donne ce chiffre dans 43%
des cas c'est l'homme qui ayant des
meilleurs garanties de revenus ou de
salaire et bien garde le logement c'est
seulement un tiers des femmes et puis
alors là on l'explique un peu moins mais
propriétaire du parc privé lou plus
facilement à un homme qui a une femme
bon très surprenant quelles sont les
solutions c'est hyper complexe
évidemment il y a pas de solution
magique on peut quand même regretter que
dans le débat politique le logement soit
quand même un peu le parent pauvre on en
a pas beaucoup parlé pendant la dernière
camp après c'est très complexe et
technique c'est effectivement très
technique il y a beaucoup de logements
vacants alors on peut se poser la
question aussi les représentations
pourquoi on est propriétaire on aurait
plus tendance à louer à un homme avec
enfant divorcé qui a une femme divorcée
avec ses enfants en attendant la
Fondation Abbé Pierre dit que c'est
évidemment un échec moi je dirais même
au-delà parce que quand on voit tous ces
malaugé ce sont des femmes et aussi des
enfants c'est surtout une honte
collective merci parti pris signé Fanny
guinothée merci les affranchis à très
vite merci Elsa on se retrouve demain
oui avec plaisir Victor Castanet grand
merci d'être venu sur le château LCP les
fossoyeurs édition augmentée de 10
chapitres inédits c'est à dire chez
Fayard très belle soirée sur LCP on est
en retard désolé
[Musique]